[Music]
good evening I'm Stuart Brandt from the
long now foundation and this is an
evening whose title is the extreme
present Brian Eno likes to say that art
is about art and artists always paying
attention to itself kind of the way
fashion does and I was sort of pushing
out the thing that was art just now or
fashion just now and also so it's it's
buried in in the extreme present but it
is because it's art looking in both
directions and so fashion in a sense art
in a sense in a different sense are
always examining the passing show for
what they quote mean or what else can be
discerned in all of this stuff pouring
past and one of the very best at doing
that is this be here tonight Doug
Copeland Stewart thank you very much for
that what a pleasure to be here in this
building with astonishing acoustics it's
a real treat I'm gonna try and project I
have this voice which sometimes does not
stick to eardrums so if I do become
mumbly you're welcome to channel my
mother and say your mom bleh and I will
stop here we are tonight the long now
welcome I got thinking about the two
expressions long now and extreme present
I realize I don't quite know the
definitive meaning of long now so Stuart
and I are going to be talking later
tonight that will be my first question
to ourselves which is what is long
long now extreme present what is the
extreme present in a short form this is
the extreme present where you had the
future in the present coexisting I was
born in 1961 and a lot of my sensibility
was informed by the dystopic sci-fi film
and TV of the 70s and growing up the
future is always 2000 and by 2000 it
would be like a Charlton Heston movie
there would be no water no oil no food
no anything and then 2000 came and went
and then we got smartphones then we got
Google and then suddenly the future
which was always out there in the
horizon began getting closer and closer
and closer and suddenly I realized that
we're inside it this is strange
tingly scents that we all kind of know
but we're gonna discuss tonight through
various channels I thought I'd start
with some art projects I do since about
2000 I've been doing art projects using
all sorts of medium media and in all
sorts of ways you might say that art is
about space and that writing is about
time sometimes there are hybrid forums
like film or TV or what have you but
that's sort of one rule of thumb here is
a project and this began I was in the
National Building Museum in Washington a
few summers ago and there is a show
there and upstairs there was this
exhibition called Lego towers and they
had the Petronas Towers they had Empire
State Building the usual suspects so I
walked through dum de dum and then they
had these big bins filled with Lego of
all type and kids would sit in there and
they would make something usually about
this big and then the parents become on
we're off to see the Lincoln Memorial
and they'd have to dump what they made
in the bins and then the next group of
kids would come in and they would like
pile the structures on top of each other
forming these fantastically
counterintuitive totems and so here what
I did
had a number of events at the Vancouver
Art Gallery one was called cocktails and
Lego and adults came in and we had a
beverage sponsor and people made these
forms and then we had afternoon builds
with children but for me every module
you see up there usually represents
about three hours of someone's time and
and then once he's grown made I just
stitched him together to create a
language for doing that so I look at
this this is sort of like a more of a
timecode of a certain period my life the
nests these are hornet wasp nest that
had been bundled together and just put
up in the wall and they have this
wonderful sort of 19th century trompe
l'oeil feeling like p tose and so I got
to thinking about evolutionary time and
biological time and then there's
cultural time and I got to thinking well
what if well my cousin he's an
entomologist we began thinking what if
we could trick bees or Hornets into
making colored bees nest and we couldn't
figure out a way of doing it so I
actually went into my own books I began
chewing them up and then spinning them
out and turning them into the nest that
you see here and now as you can see they
have a sort of Museum of Natural History
feeling to them I would do these books I
would watch law and order the TV show I
was addicted and I would chew the pages
and appellate and it got really bad I
drank out my saliva ducks I never ever
allowed it you a piece of paper ever
again but I think this is just one way
of looking at the opposite of the
extreme present maybe this is actually
the law now that we're seeing here and
then you know what I thought I would do
here is I read it's wonderful to be here
and I'm not selling a new book or
anything I'm just here to talk and to
think out loud and I'm gonna read out a
very short piece
yeah I wrote I've already called him for
the Financial Times weekend magazine
I've been doing that for a few years and
so we're talking about time and this is
last summer in a London hotels breakfast
room I was reading the times all waiting
for my ride to show up and what without
thinking much about it I looked at the
top of the page to see what time of day
it was I blinked oh ok Doug the top of
the page is not a toolbar you see into
across some sort of new line with
technology and this experience is what I
call a future blip a small hike who like
moment when it dawns on you that you're
no longer in the past another blip a few
days ago I walked around the house
looking for a newspaper so I could pack
a box I realized I didn't have me a
newspaper I hadn't had newspapers in a
while and ended up using newspaper left
in a studio trashcan that came in boxes
from eBay purchases and then finally
today I was wondering what it would be
like to live in Antarctica so I googled
Antarctica and the word party I put in a
word party because it would probably
take me to the blog of someone younger
and more likely to be posting images
online and I was right and I've now
learned that hipsters are starting to
colonize the final continent it is
incontestable that we are collectively
rebuilding the way that we process
information for example notice that when
we tell them about an idea they want you
want into search research later we don't
focus on the idea so much as how to
search for it search words establish
future and locate ability when you get
home just googled mother Teresa lawsuit
and topless and you'll find out what
you're looking for right away
now the way we are collectively
redefining search ability is indeed a
reflection on the way we now
collectively file away information in
our brains or the ways that we don't one
of the great joys of life is that we're
all getting much better knowing what it
is we no longer need to know
freedom from memorization and having
said this is a part of me that misses
being able to [ __ ] people at dinner
parties without having the iPad came out
before dessert to sink an urban legend
or debunk a stretched truth I wonder if
nostalgia for the 20th century brain is
a waste of time while they may sometimes
miss my pre-internet brain I certainly
don't want it back you know everyone's
quick to dump on new technologies but
how quickly we forget a two hour trek to
the local library and the early 1990s to
find something as mundane as a single
tradesmen's phone number versus city 20
miles away how Cavalier we are when you
say well let me just quickly google that
what we've really just said is let me
instantaneously consult with the sum
total of accumulated human knowledge
it'll just take two shakes when I was in
art school I was a ticket collector on
Tuesday nights with local rep theatre
and this was 1983 long before a VHS and
because of my ticket stint I got in free
to see all the movies and they made a
point of seeing as many as I could
they changed every two nights an affair
can it be upscale I became an unwitting
trove of information on the Univerity
Muller and was able to see gems like the
garden of the finzi-continis and a gear
of the wrath of God a decade before they
became a staple at video stores three
decades later I was in a gas station and
central British Columbia and saw a
generic Canadian Country hoser in red
and black cloud renting a DVD copy of
Kagemusha at the counter now I was
impressed but even out in the sticks
there existed a need for art house films
and well my hosers friend asked him why
he was renting Kagemusha and he said i
think it's like a really good kung fu
the so let's do the math probably five
movies a week for four ish years in art
school makes about a thousand movies the
same time I saw as many first-run movies
as anyone else and then add on the
appalling amount of television I watched
as well as the music I consumed well in
the thousands and thousands of hours of
media devoured during art school alone
don't forget books too in magazines and
dad then add three decades more of this
sort of cultural consumption for someone
born in 1991 three decades after me even
if they spent every moment of their
waking life trying to catch up to my
media consumption by the way that's a
terrible idea
it would be futile especially since my
rate of consumption continues as high as
ever so what then gets lost and what
gets kept meat and chaff and all of that
it said that gooda was the last human
being who knew everything about the
world that it was possible to learn at
that time in that sense good good uh was
like a proto Internet but now he lives
on in my 2.0 to put in a 2.0 version
called the cloud and we're all now good
uh and again I miss my pre-internet
brain but I'm rapidly forgetting it too
and I wrote that about a year ago and
the thing between then and now is
actually haven't forgotten my year nut
brain I have no idea what it felt like
to me needed back then this by the way
is a book called bit rot which is a term
used in archiving about when digital
files spontaneously just dissolved the
electrons flowed away or what-have-you
and I realized why years ago that the
world was changing a lot faster than I
was changing and that I had to get my
act together and really go there and
change the way I was looking at the
world writing about the world
experiencing and interpreting it and so
these are some other works that come
from the sort of investigation is the QR
series these are very very large
canvases they're acrylic on linen and
they're 6x6 and of course they're QR
codes
and these paintings were notionally they
were about things we probably can't read
that sorry things that you would say to
a person a hundred years before you were
born or person a hundred years after you
were born
so station statements about life or
death or how it felt to be alive here on
earth and after a while they became
almost like secular prayers and so the
whole series was going off to Shanghai
to my dealer there and and we're gonna
call it basically a show about time
travel and that was in April 19 2011 God
and so I opened my email in the morning
and my dealer sends me this
I just find it astonishing how he could
actually ban time travel so in the end
this show and end up going to China and
I can I guess what they didn't want how
about thing in China is ideology for
money era sort of cross contaminating
another titles just we heard now I'm
gonna read another piece for you here
I've spent much of my life waiting for
the future to happen yet I've never
really felt like we were there and then
in this past year it's almost instantly
become impossible to deny that we are
now all magically and collectively
living in that far off place we what's
called the future it's here that feels
on it it feels like that magical moment
when someone's pulled a practical joke
on you but you just haven't quite
realized it yet what's going on and we
keep on waiting for the reveal but it is
always going to be imminent and we'll
never quite happen I think that's the
future what was it that we pulled that
pulled us out of the present and dumped
us into this future was it too much
change too quickly one too many friends
showing us a cool new out that cost 99
cents and illuminates thousands of jobs
and what remains of the industrial
heartland
maybe it was too much freakish weather
that put us into the future or maybe it
was texting almost entirely replacing
speaking on the phone or maybe it was
Angelina Jolie's pre-emptive mastectomy
or maybe it was an adolescent comedy
about North Korea almost triggering a
nuclear war
or maybe it was Charlie Hebdo or I mean
how long that much of what defines the
future is the forced realization that
there are many people who don't want a
future and who don't want the future
that they instead want eternity now I
feel like I'm in the future when I see
something cool in the time lag between
seeing it and reaching for my iPhone
cameras down to about two seconds as
opposed to 30 seconds it would have
taken me a few years back I feel like
I'm in the future whenever I look for
images of things online and half the
ones I see or water marked and for sale
I feel like in the future when I
daydream of binging on season four of
house of cards my new laptop that weighs
nothing and never overheats and it's
battery goes on for ages how long has
this weird sensation of future ASSA tea
going to last is it temporary maybe
society will go through a spontaneous
technological law allowing the insides
of our brains to take a time holiday and
feel like we're back in 1995 not 2015
but that's probably not going to happen
ever
is it healthy to live in the future I
suspect not I really don't think that
we're not really built for permanent
high-speed change accelerated
acceleration so will there come a
collective cracking point and if so what
would a collective cracking point look
like 2016 elections
it may not be a riot or a referendum it
might be that we all wake up one morning
and suddenly we realize or not middle
class or working class or anything we're
basically just here and existing and
only the Internet makes it bearable
someone asked me last week in the long
run is technology our Savior or is it
our demise
and I thought it over and the thing is
we made technology it's only an
expression of our humanity so it's wrong
to think of it as something given us too
given to us by aliens so it's wrong we
think of technology lately I guess the
question my friend was really asking our
humans gonna kill themselves the answer
would be the exact same answer that
would have been given to you ten years
ago two thousand years ago or 1000 years
in the future we're still around so the
answer is no but still this doesn't
change the fact that we're stuck living
inside the future where we're stuck
worrying about this question for all of
our waking hours and I suppose that
abandoning one's pre-internet brain is
the only intelligent adopt a strategy
necessary for mental health in the world
of a perpetual future
how much future ossineke in our brains
explode how much future ASSA tea can our
brains accept before they explode or
implode I wonder if maybe the sensation
of future ASSA tea is a mental tic
applicable only to people born before a
certain window and time closed the state
of mind specific to those who remember a
world at once possessed at present tense
Millennials are lucky in that they have
nothing to she had nothing to trigger
'try status and nothing to unlearn for a
recent museum show I made t-shirts that
read I miss my pre-internet brain and we
photographed the one 17-year old models
I try to imagine a world without a
present tense the Millennial world where
time as a perpetual five seconds from
now and if I squint my brain for lack of
a better analogy I can almost started
get it right
those pioneers I talked about those
pioneers who settled the continent
leaving behind them a trail of abandoned
pianos and sofas and wooden raft
dressers they were shedding weight in
order to progress towards what they knew
to be their inevitable destiny
I remember once reading with pioneers
trapped in a forest fire lying submerged
in a swamp and breathing the air through
reeds well what remained of the past
went up in ashes and that's why I feel
like right now so it submerged in the
mud waiting for the fire to pass waiting
to emerge into a world is lighter
fantastically different and quite
possibly starting over from scratch I'm
gonna show a few more things here I went
to art school in 8284 in Vancouver in
Canada and someone who is very very
important to me back then was artist
named Jenny Holzer and friends of mine
and God had gone to Soho in New York and
brought back with them they ripped some
of the original truisms sheets off the
boy the plywood they looked as like my
brain just turned inside out like a
t-shirt and I realized that words on the
words could be art art supplies in
themselves and so what happened then was
I was doing an event at a Vancouver
nightclub and we had to get people to
come to it so I wanted to make posters
but no one in Vancouver walks everyone
drives a car so what he put out there on
a piece of paper that people driving by
at 40 miles an hour can read and so
began as a stead of sort of picking up
her Jenny Holtz are left off but the
idea here was write something that would
make perfect sense to someone else um
one from 20 years ago scratching their
head so of course there's this one which
we talked about in this one here as well
and I'm just going to shuffle through it
to these and they're not in any real
sequence and each one of them so
postulates a critique or an overlooked
point of view or something gone awry I
really do miss doing nothing you know if
you sit on a park bench now doing
nothing you look like you should be
getting arrested and this is a variation
on doing nothing this is kind of spooky
argentina's middle class banished what
about ten years ago and now venezuela is
vanishing and sort of something we're
all talking about everywhere in the
world right now and what will replace it
probably will be a global mono class and
the corollary of this is have an actual
skill be able to cook be able to perform
an appendectomy know how to change a
diaper but how is something you can
actually do now I don't know if you can
read this
this actually went up in the Denver
Biennale a few years back
it went up one week before Detroit went
bankrupt and everyone's like how the
hell did you know that and I say you
don't need to know the specifics just
that's the overall trend it just
happened to be right on target and I
think I mean some like 1.5 percent of
the populace isn't in jail right now and
this is loop system and I saw it like
what if you're in jail and you're
shopping on eBay and it seemed like sort
of the most modern thing you could
possibly do this one can get you in
trouble in certain parts of the world
it's true unhealthy people they consume
our medical services they eat more food
they drive their cars longer they
basically they're great for capitalism
spooky
this is a process I call d narration it
is for someone like myself for 1961 you
I grew up the sense that well you're you
born your life has a narrative thrust it
has high points low points and when you
die it's had as you've had a story so to
speak and I think what's happening to
replace that is that you have people
feeling more that they're just one unit
out of seven point six billion other
units which I think if you're from 1961
and me is a little bit of a comedown but
if you're most of the planet like wow
like you're part of the gang now and you
get to have a voice and you now count so
we have to recalibrate expectations in
all areas well we are basically a very
ungrateful species I mean imagine going
back 20 years ago you know you can have
the answer to any question you want like
right away free and you were in the
planet and you say surely not that would
be a golden age for Humanity that's
almost inconceivable and yet now we're
like next
this is who we all know it we are all
smarter we just feel stupid this is okay
the moment that AI gets to the point
where they can predict what you're going
to do and say and everything you can
basically have something in your to ball
you can have you can crowdsource your
you can crowdsource yourself using only
yourself I think you just wasted a
minute of your life on that last one it
does not need to be what what's it call
a the synecdoche the semantics the
singularity doesn't have to be the
singularity it just has to be smarter
than us
that's right middle class is sacred you
can't make any fun of it so I think this
actually is the future
boo-ki again
and don't we all just get tired of
seeing something new every day of our
life would it be great to take a
progress holiday
my mother genuinely believes us a few
years ago I went out my my halloween
costume I got a big piece of Plexiglas
and I wrote the word shutterstock on it
I walked around all night like this and
in the morning if you publish a new
stock in Manhattan sent me again a
mentos email from their morning meeting
I I had a manly tear over that one no
this is very good sort of hmm
you know what is the Enlightenment what
what is enlightenment where is it going
and his technology really are only late
Hollywood
like oh it's like how far are we from
Sand Hill Road here tonight brexit
really does sometimes well this didn't
even my friend Samuel and my friend
death no this isn't Roger down last
summer and this is big you can be in the
back the past is now useless and it's
funny to watch the Dutch go buying their
bikes like perhaps the past really is
useless I'll think about that this is
sort of what we're here to talk about
tonight this is kind of true like the
future didn't always exist I do not
quite sure when the future began it
sounds like the next Jim Glick book but
at what point did we start thinking of
the future as being something that will
be different from today probably a lot
of people here in the audience who would
know the answer to that perhaps during
Q&A you can give us the answer they just
hang out together and so I did this one
about half year ago and before brexit
and before the election and craziness
it's like ah and I kind of think we are
at some weird point right now with
technology or numbers or logarithmic
technologies but I think the one thing
that democracy really needs right now I
more than absolutely anything is some
sort of electoral morning-after pill
where in the morning everyone's like we
voted for what holy [ __ ] okay we're
doing this again
but then serve the ontology surrounding
nowadays well maybe you end up with the
exact same boat it's just there's more
votes on each side or maybe that means
you have a third boat and a fourth boat
that's the thin edge of the wedge so
basically we're stuck with one election
we all know this you all know this in
our bones and this is kind of weird this
is you know the corollary of this one is
there's something really seductive in
that if the idea is really really stupid
it makes it even easier to believe and I
don't know what the name of that is and
it's like oh we're in San Francisco we
know this okay too bad Kevin Kelley is
not here tonight what yes and this is a
what if well we had smart phones we had
Google we had iPhones and what if that's
it what if there's not going to be
anymore this is our end state you have
to make peace with what we have and then
it's like oh thank god this progress
depressing I wrote this one about three
years ago and it gets evermore true and
I guess that's where this is a project
is just came down it's in Shanghai this
is one variation on the slogan for the
21st century
this is slogans for the 22nd it was at
this Sun this big the Shanghai Himalayan
museum and outside there there was a
white lattice structure by Japanese
architectural firm and then they asked
me if I do slogans that come from a
hundred years from now and I'm hoping
you can read that it says we ran out of
trees it's a sort of structure there in
daytime
no just a Chinese version there so let's
take a break here and think what if what
a time it's not about perception what if
it's not about experience maybe it's
about grounded somehow in actual science
and so I looked into this a bit that
there's this thing called the Cronin or
maybe there's actual an actual particle
of some sort that allows us to perceive
or not perceive time and then I looked
up I mean that may be our ability
perceive time as some sort of built-in
something's gone wrong with a kind of
lepton it is some particle level and
like I have no idea really and then it
turns out that in a year a billion years
ago there was a spontaneous nuclear
fission and that if they look at the
data from those moments it looks like
they think the speed of time might not
actually be a constant that the speed of
time is actually variable and then
things just get a bit too weird and I
just put those things in just to show I
covered my bases
now what I want to do right now is I
want to read it's a quick short story
it's called George Washington's extreme
makeover let's say said everyone loves a
good before-and-after picture no even
when you take Acala day from technology
technology doesn't take a holiday from
you so on vacation three years back I
chose to read a really long and very
worthy biography of George Washington I
chose it because it was at someone's
guesthouse it was the one book in the
shelves that I could be sure contained
absolutely no technology no email smart
phones discount airline smoking hot wife
I know anything and that book delivered
and for a week I had a dream like brain
holiday one that I look now I look back
on and see it almost as a form of
ecotourism of the mind visiting a place
where there's a guarantee of relief from
like technologized brain daily brain
ecology now in the book I learned that
Washington was a worthy fellow confident
human being in a narrow and life was
short and most people were a mess an era
when healthy people caught a cold one
afternoon and they were dead by morning
importantly I learned that we're at not
Washington there would most definitely
never been a United States a man's his
historical worthiness is undeniable and
the guy was basically one of those
people who changed the world and
Washington also had appallingly bad
teeth and he spent much of his time when
he was visiting new cities inquiring
after local dentist and new procedures
but might allow him to live not in near
perpetual dental pain and discomfort and
one reason there's no image of George
Washington smiling is that the man never
smiles he didn't want his teeth or lack
thereof to show and although he was
graced by general good health he died in
1799 at the age of 67 an accomplishment
for that era he was not blessed with
bodily comfort as what we can say as if
anyone of his era he endured his
of slow healing wounds fungal infections
gastrointestinal distress and many
things that can these days be nipped in
the bud by going to Walgreens when I
began reading about Washington's chronic
discomfort I began to have a fantasy one
in which George at the age of 45 utterly
sick of being sick covered in lies
exhausted from having to his rescue
here's a napkin cumin from peril after
peril
he's teleported from atop his horse
somewhere in the scenic Virginia
countryside to a class-one cleanroom 500
feet feet beneath the exact spot 240
years later once there George has given
a big hit of Valium and he's told by a
gentle off-screen woman's voice that
he's been whisked away by the angels to
heal his body and prepare hopefully for
the task of creating and leading a new
nation at this point a crew of doctors
don't just exude on tests wearing hazmat
suits descend on Washington and begin
futzing about with his body
identifying rashes cyst abscess is gross
aches pains every other form of malady
and then Google fixing everything
Washington I'm gonna start calling him
George here he's totally okay with this
invasion because there are these are
angels well no they're not necessarily
winged but wait this well think about a
sterile pure white 21st century
environment could definitely read as a
form of heaven to someone from 9 1776
but a big part of this makeover and
healing fantasy is to ensure that George
doesn't catch any any 21st century bugs
hence the hazmat outfits and over the
ensuing few weeks George undergoes a
rigid antibiotic regimen to remove any
transmittable blood cooties he may be
harboring this allows the safe
implantation of 32 dazzling new teeth
using steel post implantation and along
the way George's skin is moisturize d
fungicides deloused and has gently
kissed with just a slight honey bronze
color by the tanning rays but wait to
Washington a redhead and his true his
makeover team needs to go easy on the
ultraviolet rays because George needs to
look like you spent a week
if Jorge looked like Georgia - Coco
Grande town it was a look odd in 1776
instead of making him look like a number
of the ruling elite it would make him
resemble a day laborer moving forward
Georgia's rogue ear nose hairs are
trimmed his dandruff is soulsand into
oblivion and his signature you might
almost call it an Andy Warhol and drag
hairstyle is fluffed and primped into
Sassoon like perfection he's become
almost borderline hot and just before
leaving the class one containment area
George is given LASIK treatment to
correct his vision as well as small hits
of Botox to loan him a slightly more
youthful appearance the garments he was
wearing when he was abducted of and I
cleaned and stored for 48 hours - 204
degrees Celsius then thawed dried and we
stitched together basically when George
is returned onto his horse in Virginia
he was a new man as you see uh we took
one founding father and turned him to
one hot daddy this new man is one super
healthy stud and he is ready to kick
some English ass the only thing that
might complicate this scenario this
makeover scenario would be if George
were to fall in love with one of his
house mad angels a twist it could place
the heart of any Hollywood producer
George would be back in 1759 pining to
reunite with say Goliath and sinewy dr.
Jennifer Crandall a parasitologist with
a chip on her shoulder an equivalent
quivering lower lip to be played by
Charlize Theron
so doctor nurse Crandall dr. Crandall
hops into the time-travel machine goes
back in time and finds George it brings
back with her some ghastly 21st century
flu wiping out 90% of the American
colonies population and wrecking history
forever
I guess the point here is that even when
you try avoiding technology it still
drives the imagination and I just wanted
I just wanted a book without smartphones
however I'm gonna try it again this
January I'm gonna be using a Kindle for
the first time and fYI I actually did a
pilot script for George Washington's
Extreme Makeover it's like it's open
Amazon this one doesn't come out in the
States until March because no publisher
wants to put out any book during a US
election cycle because publishers are
brave we all know that about publishers
so so here I'm looking back okay at time
what is it how we exist in it and I look
at what's happening Society and I do
think it boils down to three three
conditions
I was working over in Google in Europe
last year and in Europe they have the
right to be forgotten which is a very
important thing for them that you can
have your name taken off Google servers
in your own country or whatever domain
you want to take it out of it's a lot of
work so you want to be forgotten but
like how many likes did my last posting
on Facebook yeah you know what how's my
blog doing is getting traction so
there's that sort of weird
back-and-forth like like I want to be
invisible I want to be remembered
forever and then tying in to that same
sort of reality is we are still in the
early early days of the internet and you
have a Egypt like Twitter saves the day
as the the myth has it or then the
mullahs take over and this is back and
forth like groups versus individuals
versus
and the thing about the internet is so
weird is that you would never ever call
I'll call up your friend well no one
talks on the phone anymore you never
text your friend and say hey come on in
my house we'll go on the internet
together it would just be stupid and yet
for something that is such an
intrinsically solitary act if boy does
it have an uncanny ability to create or
Rhian power pre-existing groups and
finally I think this is sort of a part
of the same scenario but I don't know
what's going to triumph in the end
secularity or religion I don't know if
we're going to know for about another
100 years I do think that these three
cofactors will be in play now what I'm
going to do here the thing about the
future the thing about a secular versus
the religious if you're secular you're
boring you come into existence and you
die and you went wherever it was before
you were born and well you may be
cremated or ashes the world that we're
in right now just keeps on going and the
future still exists so if your secular
you have the future but if you're
religious then you have an afterlife or
in most religions do you have an
afterlife and the thing about the
afterlife is that it's not allowed to
communicate with the future they're
completely different realms or
territories or whatever you want to call
and it seems like the only place that
you actually have the future and the
afterworld connect is through art or
through writing or some form of
creativity and also I was watching a
documentary adam curtis's hyper
normativity inca that's type name of it
but saying that in syria in the 1980s
with the invention of suicide bombing is
that suicide bombers were actually
promised that they could be in heaven
but they could actually look back at the
world and that it was sort of this weird
loophole
that allowed you know basically people
should know better to get young twits to
strap bombs on themselves and go into
the market so it's with this notion in
mind that going to read another short
story here from the book and it's called
Vietnam quick show of hands here who
here remembers Vietnam either on TV or
ok so it's about 50/50 Vietnam was the
first thing I remember seeing on thing I
remember seeing on television I think
Lyndon Johnson and Richard Nixon both
thought it would be great to have the
war on it was a disaster actually being
on TV helped it go away much more
quickly than it would have otherwise but
they had this thing called the draft and
with the draft was the draft lottery and
they had all these ping-pong balls and
they reached in and they pulled out a
date I think the first one was September
14th and if that was your birthday then
everyone without birthday got drafted
and then there was a second number but
number three was December 30th which is
my birthday and my two older brothers
like ha ha you're gonna go to Vietnam
you're gonna die and like there's
nothing you can do and in that way
that's only possible in you're eight or
nine or ten like I couldn't sleep I
couldn't function I couldn't do anything
and it really kind of stuck in my craw I
mean my also my dad was in the Air Force
and that come I come from a family of
gun not say it was walls on everything
guns on every wall except the walls that
had dead animals cuz my brother was a
taxidermist and or else pictures my dad
in a jet and so I come from this very
hawkish family and I think that when you
write fiction you think you're writing
it for one reason then it turns out in
the end you were writing it for some
other reason I'll get there shortly
the story is called Vietnam and I will
say that there is a lot of swearing in
this so if you're I'm just letting you
know in advance
so the story begins
I am private Donald R Garland from
Bakersfield California a nice place to
grow up in as you can imagine good folk
in California California was booming my
mother used to put sour cherry pies out
on the lower ledges ax the Dutch door
just the way they cool down pies and
cartoons and I was really pleasant that
way please call me dawn on August 8th
1968 I was on an unarmed film
reconnaissance mission of rivers in the
bong-sun region and I was killed when my
you Cobras pilot got shot by sniper from
I don't know where the rear blades
snagged the remains of a palm tree and
the tail boom severed maybe took seven
seconds and all but the last thing I saw
was an orange explosion approaching my
face like lava coming down a Hawaiian
slope now I'm thinking about what I just
said and how now that sounded and that
was the thing about now everything about
it was so alien that all you had to do
is say a few place names with a few
military flourishes in kaboom it was
like describing life on Mars not
something real that was actually
happening to mean technically close to
my parents house and say Vienna or
Norway and four people back in
Bakersfield reading about now and was I
don't know it was like working them at
gunpoint to read a Chinese menu closely
no matter what you asked for all they
bring you is machine guns and dog soup
and my death in bong Swann was very
expensive aside from the costs of
raising an American child born in 1949
there were the added cost of my
attending San Diego military academy
probably set my old man back 30 grand
plus all the US government money it cost
to start a war overseas and pay to fly
me over peel my potatoes wash my laundry
buy me weapons and put me in helicopters
with pilots like my old Powell and
Baylor taking off in a Yui filled with
canisters of film that were to have been
processed and shown on CBS TV line
always got off on that maybe our footage
would be shown right before at Red
Skelton
or bewitched it cost of Vietnamese way
last money to send one of their 19 year
olds off to war the maths not hard you
grew up in a rice paddy you get a Soviet
made ak-47 for free and it's wartime
that's what Len called asymmetrical
warfare and I often wonder if someone in
Washington looked at the cost of sending
over people like me and said you know
what this is not sound King Z and I
could all next week
we've put way too much money into
raising this guy we're from Bakersfield
California that sounds expensive already
I bet his momma put out pies to cool on
a window ledge and also we can end up
dying a [ __ ] Yui Cobra crash and how
much is one of those things cost and how
did someone that expensive end up in the
shed this is crazy
don't we have a cheaper people we can
send off to that godforsaken [ __ ]
isn't that the reason we allow
Mississippi to be part of the country
yeah
where is Linda this is nuts well Linden
is in his office watching TV Linden is
not watching TV he is looking at three
TVs at once all three networks at once
he's paranoid he's gaga the moment I
landed in them I knew there was no way
we were gonna win the war there sure we
had all these Dewey's and fighter jets
and [ __ ] nan Margaret came and performed
for the USO and Danang and 66 and 68 but
we had expensive people like me playing
with big expensive toys that could never
stand a chance against inexpensive
basically cost free soldiers playing
with lots of essentially free call me
toys it's some sort of historical law
David and Goliath and plus you're always
getting crowds and stiff and deep burns
lift your beetle scabs and foot rot in
your brain worm that place was unholy
God it was home second now nothing was
familiar and everything stank and all
those latrines with ventilation by Satan
I was grateful for the orders in the
discipline actually because otherwise it
has cried all day I always wanted beer
on potato peeling duty except I went to
military academy so they'd never have me
doing that kind of chore I'd have liked
to been peeling potatoes but
at least a potatoes potato and you know
what comes from the Northern Hemisphere
potatoes don't have shuddering diesel
engines that stink in your face making
sleep impossible and potatoes aren't
yokels with teeth that look like
handfuls of dice randomly stuck into
gums
I'm just being mean I mean we were just
babies over there we were children we
shouldn't have been there is stupid we
all knew it April 1968 48 thousand men
drafted five hundred and thirty seven
thousand troops and now those pansies
bringing their doubt draft cards in New
York City were totally right to do so
you know they did suck dick I don't
think I don't think I've ever met even
one person now who thought we were gonna
win someday we all know we were [ __ ]
and maybe on Margaret thought we'd win
and we just didn't want to get killed
but then obviously I got killed and our
proof that guys were right I'd like to
talk to mr. Washington general guys
someday but time no longer exists for me
so Wow
so what's a day what's a lifetime I'd
ask him sir why did you think that war
was a good idea who said any part of
this was a good idea how old are you boy
let me see private Garland
we'll call me dawn sir I was a month shy
of 19 when I was killed Oh boohoo
sir ma'am was obviously a total [ __ ]
disaster there are you satisfied full
put wait how did how long did you know
it was a total [ __ ] disaster sir
Christ writer the gate if you want they
can go through my day timer hang on a
sec here here's to the magic moment when
it dawned on me that it was all a
colossal goat [ __ ] here it is a telex
from March 7th 1966 mr. Bob Hope demands
that he and Miss Margaret be provided
with Sealy Posturepedic mattresses with
custom molded foam pillows for her
impending visit and sir well that's all
I read that specific telex and something
inside me died I don't even think on
Margaret knew at the NAMM reality I
think the reality was Bob Hope I've been
in now before and he knew what a cosmic
[ __ ] that place really was
and he buckled it thought of an Margaret
witnessing the whole truth because if
she knew then that would show in her
performances and if it showed in her
performances than the trip troops to get
spooked and would have just put the
whole Duma thing on fast-forward well
thank you sir but what about the other
guys like me who got killed well we were
cannon fodder what else you want me to
say excuse me oh don't play dumb you and
all those other guys women too for that
matter
just cannon fodder this somehow
surprises you mr. Miller Military
Academy graduate ok I'm certain
listening so tell me more Oh dawn
this is getting tiring the thing about
males promote 17 to 25 is that nature
rigs your brains don't ask me how that
you are susceptible to you and the
stupidest [ __ ] ideas whatever they
may be and you're out there carrying a
rifle or a scimitar I don't know maybe
it's not the war maybe it's just a
bitter [ __ ] up English teacher who
wants to poison you by making you hate
all the same writers that he or she
hates I used to study English and I
remember those teachers they didn't care
about what was good or bad they just
wanted to poison all your young brains
that was just English classes it wasn't
even something and as this or well it
wasn't even something as visceral as
putting [ __ ] rich boys from
Bakersfield California out in some
godforsaken toraat [ __ ] like bong
Shan to die useless overfunded deaths oh
I see dawn oh the last time you saw
someone in their 30s ditches family run
off to certain death in some dumb [ __ ]
war never it's a brain thing males from
17 to 25 are genetically thought they
will do anything for anybody and they'll
think it's the right thing they have no
sense of risk assessment that's a bit on
the cynical side sir no brother young
Dumbo's like you have been going off to
war to fight crazy batshit stuff since
the dawn of man makes me embarrassed to
be a human being sometimes well thank
you for your candor sir oh you're
welcome dawn so you maybe think I'm just
angry for having been sent off to
cynically die
pointless war with no clear good guys or
bad guys we're young men were turned
into zombies and ghouls and we're
everything good in the world was covered
with the mixed years to gasoline and
Styrofoam pellets and then satellite but
then what you don't know is that I went
to a museum once in Toronto in Ontario
Canada 1965 I think and it was this
summer my parents we were we're all
arguing my brothers were being a real
pain I simply walked away from them all
and I walked up this echoey traveled
travertine stairs to another floor and
into the rooms where they kept the
displays of taxidermy life on earth and
it changed the way I thought walking
through those chambers it didn't feel
like a boring high school field trip at
all not in the least it was the most
wonderful trip ever I looked inside the
glass display cases and they had an
Alaska king crab with red prickly legs
longer in my daddy's arms and there was
a skeleton of the Triceratops and there
was several extinct passenger pigeons
and a fungus that secreted this red
blobs shaped like a soccer ball there
were foxes and butterflies and deep sea
creatures little dangling light things
in front of your mouths and a clam size
that clamped you all the size of my uh
my Fairlanes trunk and I just looked at
all this life so much life life in every
shape and form and size and I stopped
there and I thought well here it is I am
Alive it's just as everything here in
these cases was once alive so what is it
and this thing called life this thing
called life that I share with all these
creatures here and my parents were
furious when they found me I've been
gone an hour and we still had to visit
some castle thing a few miles away I
didn't care if they were mad because
I've been shown a small window and time
and time is what we're here to talk
about tonight and I knew I've been given
something precious in my just 16 years
on the planet at that time
chance to share earth with all these
other creatures it kept me going when I
was out there and they shed and I
thought I could be a butterfly fish off
the Australian coast I thought I could
be a leopard in a Kenyan tree waiting to
pounce on prey below I thought I could
be one of those three dogs at lawyer
outside that mast and I you we anyone
here we could have been a coral reef a
cuddlefish the gust of pollen bright
young bright yellow praying mantis
longer than my foot I was alive one more
sentence my dog my name was dawn my name
was dawn Donald Garland and yeah that's
really hard
my name is dawn Donald Garland and now
I'm gone and I miss you earth I really
miss you dearly okay thank you
[Applause]
see a little bit about what got you in
that last story and whoa you know
writing is not supposed to be therapy
it's not meant to be working your
problems oh you think you're doing one
thing and here I was telling you about
growing up in a house surrounded with
dead animals only just then do I make
the connection that this guy's in a room
filled with dead animals it's like
that's how that's how long I can go home
before you really figure out you know
what's going on you know and then also I
maybe talked about the earlier my dad
died a few weeks back yes and he was in
the military just all adds up and so did
you grow up on previous posts hither and
yon and although I was born in Germany
look at the piece over there and then
more or less moved to Vancouver at the
end does it just a very hawkish guns and
ammo kind of family and how did that
conversation of the family work out over
the decades I don't play well my dad was
kind of like this GI Joe action figure I
mean he did everything he put his way
through med school flying planes for the
Air Force he was the downhill ski race
champion and he was a scuba just did
everything and so I think and I forget
you're an over or younger I'm number
three or four I'm the family Martian and
I mean everyone's got their role and as
long as I'm weird and fine and the
family ecosystem
a while back you've you've done
nonfiction as well as fiction and in the
sense this book you were just reading
from is a little both but when you're
nonfiction this was a short biography of
Marshall McLuhan oh yeah and I'm one of
the artists who was you know swerved by
books and I actually got to spend an
afternoon with him ons and he seems to
have been taken up by artists more than
almost any other yeah part of the
society and he seems to have understood
the world through art and artists in the
frame of mind the artists have yeah more
than most
so as you took on doing that biography
you presumably already had some ideas
about him of how he defected you
whenever in the 80s I guess you know and
then you do some more research and then
what happens because now you're gonna
crystallize those two times that you
were dealing with Marshall well that
work out I shall say I ll be full
disclosure I didn't know anything about
Marshall McLuhan until 2006 and I got
dragged kicking and screaming into doing
that look I mean I was even here working
at Wired nearly 1990s and Marshall was
the patron saying right and I was like
all gotta go do this biography I came
out on coals and I realized at the end
of the I wish I could do another
biography completely redo the one I did
but through a chain of historical and
intellectual circumstances there
unrepeatable he was able to see the
Internet and beyond the Internet for
that matter the only thing he didn't
know about was the interface or how it
actually work so instead he would try
and describe you know PayPal using James
Joyce or something and it sounded just
crazy to people why would a question it
feels like number one what was like yeah
the time you spent with him mm-hmm
and at what point did it you twig onto
the fact that he was really he's onto
something and then when the internet
started happening like oh this is why
when did when did it come together for
you well in the idea of the medium is
the message was a profound in an
artistic insight and that he was
bringing basically the whole body of
literary
thinking which was his frame too
intensely contemporary things like
advertising and I think the book that I
got the most from actually was fun I
think called cultures or business which
is consists almost entirely of ads on
one side of the spread and then his
commentary on what was really going on
in that ad on the other side and he saw
advertising as the good news that was
actually the main event going on in the
various publications that carried
advertising and the news was there just
to sort of force you to get onto the
same page with the good news and the
advertising he had this weird sense of
humor you know sometimes you can't those
parents send you these like things have
been forwarded like eight hundred times
like really bad cartoons or something
mm-hmm that was kind of his sense of
humor
so was he mad as a hatter was he just
like blah blah blah blah blah blah
definitely blah blah blah I was working
with Jerry Brown and in his first
administration here and the personal
staff and part of my deal was to bring
people like he would come spend part
their day with Governor Brown and we
brought in Marshall and two Catholics
you know it converted Catholic and a
born Catholic and sort of hit it off at
that level anyway in Jerry Brown is in
the music intellectual about all things
and Marshall McLuhan is you know beauty
intellectual all the way down
he's like a leaf blower and I think the
fund for Jerry especially was watching a
person stand up in front of press and
absolutely boggle them bamboozle them
blow their minds and let Jerry just sit
back and smile and watch somebody else
take that whole weird press relations
process and evaporate it right in front
of everybody's eyes and the press
themselves are seeing this happening so
he in person was a
wacky seeming present friendly bizarre
one of the auger ducks we've had an
inspiring character yeah does that match
what you studied a little bit yeah he
had this thing called Christmas morning
syndrome and you became Catholic quite
late in his 30s and he couldn't wait to
die and get off earth and go into the
next realm you thought earth was doomed
you had that really negative side they
don't know if you know though I didn't
know yeah yeah I know he couldn't wait
to go to the great Hereafter okay I got
some questions Andy we asked is
capitalism accelerating oh what a great
question is it is capitalism susceptible
to entropy is capitalism moral I guess
this got back the question of
enlightenment is what was the
enlightenment where did it take us and
what is the crisis point we're at right
now
and I don't know I like reading there's
a Eric Hobsbawm he was the editor of
Marxism today and I mean I'm not
necessarily political but he did a
wonderful book was called the age of
extremes
and so short has through the 20th
century and he always looked to do
history in terms of capitalism and
ownership and even now he's been dead
however long who owns controlled
production has actually been or never
been more relevant and so it is
capitalism getting is it accelerating
yes I think I think it is and in a very
unattractive way - and does that shatter
at some point or just it's infinitely
accelerated I think it's actually I mean
it almost shattered back in 2008 you
know we money came this close to
breaking and hat off and never being
fixable again so that's to you of a
pre-shock of the big earthquake to come
oh boy 2022 it's
okay
Christopher Ilan C asks in the past
culture was edited by newspaper and
publishing editors the internet is not
edited in the old sense what's the
impact of all that on democracy and
everything else well number one impact
is that we have this wonderful thing
called reddit yeah okay which I love
what you how is it if we're living
inside that right now I mean talk about
living inside the why asymptote like
every conceivable mode of thinking
Donald Trump all I needs is a Twitter
account pre and like that's his
fundraising and he becomes Donald Trump
it's just all pirate power relationships
have been inverted I really worry about
newspapers now especially with a
headlock is that they're really circling
the drain
and what's going to replace them and how
do you find a new source that is
dependent and sustainable and that might
not be possible
so we're is a bumpy ride coming up let's
try another angle on that suppose that
and maybe the election in 2016 has
there's a sort of example of a lot of
the non crazy non Twitter aspects of
current public discourse going on about
the selection it's being generated by
relatively long-form journalists at
print places like Washington Post New
York Times now Washington Post you know
it's sort of got subsidized back into
health by Jeff Bezos Maritimes is
hanging on this sort of the preeminent
national newspaper Guardian and few
others but the the major sort of anti
Twitter part of the discourse has been
coming from print journalists does this
suggest that in the ecology of swarming
accelerations that you're talking about
as some things go faster the system
rewards some things for basically
holding still and staying healthy well I
mean people talk like how do I get
published in the year 2016 and I think
the answer is that it's always been just
as hard to get published no matter what
year you're in it's just it's something
else is like like some other wolf is
like clawing at the door from some other
direction and I think maybe we're only
meant to have a finite number of
newspapers and maybe you know having
tens of 20s or 30s a thousands of
newspapers was a historical aberration
that was never meant to be it was
replaced by zillions of Twitter accounts
the ones at Twitter accounts and
hopefully New York Times LA Times
Washington Post or some sort of load of
sanity I mean we're talking about this
in a green room like the the last debate
honestly if if Donald Trump had said
Hillary people just don't like you no
one would have been surprised and like
Hillary look at what you're wearing and
like no one would have been surprised
and that again the power inversion the
the role inversion it's just shocking
and I think right now in this month it's
almost like like a teenager that's got
like a whole brand new science kit and a
brand new stereo and a brand new
electric guitar or something and
everyone's just going crazy watching you
know all the old stuff die that's really
negative down here about that
basically what am sternest algae's all
this keeps going you had a few things
about that what's the role of nostalgia
extreme presences asks bill bill bill
bill sing out hi Bill
never you know there you never meet
anyone just called Bill anymore do you
it's like like hi Doug you go to which
you went to Disneyland there probably
wouldn't have little license plates
would build on them anymore or Doug
wears nostalgia fit into all this
well okay being born when I was born I
remember the way things were
and we're how they're changing and I'm
lucky you'll be able to see where they
went but I have a lot of baggage you
have to shed a lot of his biases a lot
of nostalgia I got this yet I don't
think nostalgia it may not be of any use
in the new order it may be nostalgia is
just a filter you put in the photo to
make it look old-fashioned or something
sometimes I wonder you know with
something like search engines in in
France and Germany everyone says
Google's got too much power we have to
like like do something about it well
think about this what can you do it's
not like AT&T being chopped up into baby
bells
you can't take a search engine and like
your friends gets pornography and
Germany Germany gets ecommerce and
Holland gets sports so it's not
structured that way and so so then what
happened so your government takes over
your search engine
well welcome to China so so what are you
gonna do is it something that can only
be left in the hands of private
enterprises or you know they're there's
nothing in our human history that maps
onto what's happening right now nothing
and I mean remember growing up I'm sure
he did every time you got near to your
mm everything spiked up the the y-axis
we're now in the asymptotes and that's
kind of my friend Gregor he says you
know what Doug just surf the tornado she
was like no you find yourself coming
around it it's kind of burning the Manny
I'm not burning that I think you are
okay
second question from Andy Lee do you
google yourself for facts about yourself
you might have forgotten do I pleasure
myself what Google yourself oh god no oh
oh God
have you looked at your Wikipedia entry
or things like that no no I the school's
brave dog probably between people right
now are looking at it you're missing
this goes back to 1991 and that I've
never been able to read about myself
I've never been able to because it's
once the open that door you can never
close it but you can and you know once
you're famous and I'm sorry that
happened to you you know you are going
to meet yourself they hide the mirrors
everywhere I do have so many checks for
vandalism every so often mm-hmm
and also whenever I'm being introduced
somewhere I can tell who am I correct
Wikipedia and who went to my website or
whatever right no no googling I couldn't
do it Alex
people are getting stranger names now
pit bartz believe that thank you for a
fool name if you could teach a ninth
grade class on any subject what would
you teach one of the most important
skills for today's high schoolers oh god
that's such a good question okay okay
and then maybe part of the way to think
about this is bearing in mind that ninth
graders are picking up all kinds of
stuff from their peers and the media
they're using and stuff like that so you
is a good ninth grade teacher probably
going to be hip to all of that as much
as you can within reason with your aging
neurons and and inability to forget a
lot of important stuff they're just not
very useful
nevertheless you would like to impart
something these ninth graders that
they're not picking up on their own
what was that allows the brain cells
that remain to be stronger and more
vigorous okay I think there should be a
class called what you don't need to know
and how to look at a fact or something
and you know I don't need this but no if
you need to get it later you know where
to get it I mean I think that the amount
of space in my head that's wasted by
remembering the phone numbers from the
1970s or something that's a very trivial
example but you really don't need to
know that much
it's amazing Holly like get away with a
ninth grade class know about that
well okay okay well like okay okay okay
girls here's how we go shoplifting and
guys here's you know how do you set fire
to your body spray to turn it into a
blowtorch knowing what not to no I think
I I wonder if history's sort of needs a
new branding or something and maybe just
instead of calling a history class tree
calling it the past and I'm calling
because you no longer giving it calling
it capital H history you're allowing
people to be a bit more neutral about
what's happened in the world just a bit
more neutral neutral teaching neutrality
say how would you do that because one
falls into two easy affiliations and
then gets lost down there rabbit holes
or what well maybe a better class would
be like points of view multiple points
of view yeah with you without feeling
like so like scenario planning for the
individual psyche know something I like
that idea
no I do the kids one question since my
beard went white I get asked to do
commencement speeches and no it's true I
look wise beyond my years
and what I get it's not even from the
students it's been the parents it's like
how do I make my child
safe against the future and and there's
two things you can do one is figure out
what is you enjoy doing because no
matter what happens in your life you
like making shoes like Lepidoptera you
like you know making banana splits
you're always going to be able to do it
regardless of what the technology is and
number two comes from McLuhan who used
his metaphor of the Maelstrom the Sailor
is caught in the vortex of water going
into the planet and that one sailor who
survives is hanging on to a barrel
because it was the lightest thing and
that the modern equivalent of the guy
who held on to the barrel was the need
to look for patterns and pattern
recognition and you may not find those
patterns but at least to search for them
we'll keep you psychically healthy so
maybe that's the course to be teaching
grade 9 is how to spot a pattern and
maybe you give them ten articles and
there's this pattern embedded in them
embedded in them and you know what it is
so like what was it I think that might
be the sort of thinking we need in the
future Gregory Bateson used to do that
with college students which is he would
give them a dead crab and then something
else that was kind of complicated and
asked them to prove that one of these
things that once been alive just using
the evidence may be reporting it the
wrong way maybe if if they get the
answer right to something was give them
candy I mean it you might be
overthinking this teaching how to not
overthink is its own discipline you're
one of the most productive hard-working
artists I know and probably have a
number of plates you're spinning
simultaneously but you want to say
anything about what you're working on
now and what feels like it's coming oh
well okay I spent the time at Google and
it was spending time long time with
engineers and for me it was mostly about
being
immersed in search culture and looking
at the sorts of things people search for
don't search for here's a question what
do you think is the single most active
Internet moment of the week most active
internet moment of the week drawing a
blank quit
it's 901 in the morning Los Angeles time
that's a single heaviest traffic woman
the can the possible reason for that is
the west coast is waking up these coasts
is hard at work Europe was probably just
shutting down for the afternoon and
that's in the traffic is at its highest
I did a project there it's a book so if
you want to be in the middle of internet
time when it's really hot I want to be
in that zone if you want to knock if
you're going on Twitter say that's
that's when you go on I guess but I
think and there's a book project to do
with them that came out of it but what
came out of it more was just to serve
this way we've gotten used to having the
answer to everything and I had this
scenario like the worst thing you could
probably ask me if I Google myself well
the analogy to that would be what if you
had a dinner party for six people and
then you're able to hear what they said
about you and the car driving away and
like that would be just terrifying and
then so how do you like using that
building upon that incrementally to like
ever insanely larger amounts of
information about other people and it's
what is this project which is it's
called Panama for reasons I won't go
into and so I'm doing it with HBO right
now and it's just a six pack a six
half-hour series on sort of the ever
escalating where the information is
dumped on us and then how bored we get
with its quickly and how we want more
and more and more so I think that's what
that's what I'm working on right now
almost other things you know one line of
yours that's in a book that you'll
probably be able to identify don't
remember which one you noted that has
anybody ever actually looked at
television from back in the 60s or 70s
or some point when the establishes kind
of
Golden Age and you look back at
television that and it's just terrible
it's just awful it's but this is sort of
a wonderfulness to the awfulness
sometimes ah okay III what would I watch
this is like five minutes omnia i watch
old episodes of Mary Tyler Moore and
they're so formulaic they write
themselves i watched episodes of the
Outer Limits or The Twilight Zone
because I know that they had to write
them on the fly because they had to do
it take the next one up the next week
right and there's kind of a reality even
though it's scripted that permeates the
scripts because they were also done in
that so quasi Darwinian environment they
had to get done so I like that I mean I
you did you watch Mad Men at all I did
for a while okay I mean it was fun
because it was a period when I was you
know paying attention and he was in New
York when I was in Fort Dix in the army
and stuff like that it's still hard to
imagine you ever being in the Army why
we might be to run a little close order
drill right here Dean
you know Mad Men everyone ever everyone
I know who is a part of that reality
says swears that it's absolutely
accurate that is actually exactly how it
went down
which is so misogynist so like it's so
wrong on so many levels
yeah but it's what happened and so
that's where you have to learn you know
how to cope is multiple points of view I
suppose okay yeah it was part of what
one does this one looks that oh my god
all the smoking how horrible all the
messiness about dealing with nature how
horrible all the cruelty that women how
horrible and you know then if you sort
of step back and you think what things
that we're doing now normally will look
that bad oh god okay watching that movie
19:45 notorious with Cary Grant and
Ingrid Bergman and they're at a party
this is the opening of the movie and
they're both sloshed and like oh my god
I'm so incredibly drunk let's go for a
drive and and then they go for drive and
then they light up cigarettes and then
the cop pulls them over as I hey you
kids
and and and I'm trying to think like
okay what in the audience right now
would be horrifying some 100 years what
is the spittoon of tomorrow like a
cigarette of tomorrow it could be
leather shoes it could be maybe it's
anti intellectual future and the fact
that you're wearing eyeglasses as in the
People's Revolution it makes you all get
sent off to count for something right
it's not going to be or the fact that we
all have cell phones in our pockets that
is giving us all it could be anything
but that's kind of spooky like where's
the camera hello posterity
what are we doing right now that's like
scaring the crap out of you somehow the
spittoon brought it well you know what
they say about spittoons don't never
drink from a spittoon because once you
start you can't stop because it's all
connected
okay that's also true about history I
saw my first spittoon in South America
and like what status get to it oh my god
I thought that was like something that
only existed in Elmer Fudd cartoon not
in the year 1900 you could be like a
hotel here in San Francisco I did long
oyster fills with like tobacco noid
flavor and I better like expunge it
immediately with or without accuracy and
that vessel before what were they
thinking okay I'm on the right I'm
venting okay Lee Kuan Yew wasn't here
yet he fixed that and Singapore um kind
of a final question and you know there's
a spectrum that people keep calling up
between pessimism and optimism and
suspect for mean anything to you and
where are you on it why well ask George
Orwell what class he was he said oh I'm
upper lower middle class
and so you're smeared across it or what
are you saying
well there's reality there's what I was
taught was going to expect and maybe you
two you know though just the future
being this dystopic nightmare you know
and here we are and it's actually great
you know and if we just not listen to
people who are pushing our button that's
just because the moment technologies
that set up so those specific people can
push our buttons we could actually very
easily enter the next glorious days of
enlightenment I mean not just here in
the West but as a planet together and I
think maybe the ultimate course is just
like okay like how to just let stop
finding out who those idiots are and
just ignore them and just go forward and
I guess not sense I'm optimistic on the
other hand there's 2022 to be determined
thank you for coming
[Applause]
[Music]
you